قذف صاروخيه استهدف فوق قاعده للتحالف
الدوليه في الشدادي في الحسكه السوريه دون
اصابه
نظام طهران يهدد محطه تلفزه ايرانيه في
لندن وقراصنه يخترقون موقعا لوكاله فارس
ويحذفون معلومات من اجهزهتها
نحو ثلث اوكرانيا دون كهرباء واصلنسكي
وجوه انتقادات علنيه لعمده كير
[موسيقى]
طبتم مطابقه اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى نشره
اخباريه من العربيه
افادى متحدثون العسكري ان صاروخين استهدفا
قوات التحالف التي تدعمها الولايات
المتحده في شمال شرق سوريا دون وقوع خساره
اضرار وافادت وكاله الانباء هوار الكرديه
انفجارات في محيط مدينه الشدادي بالحسكه
قرب الحدود بين سوريا والعراق ولم تذكر
الوكاله اي تفاصيل اخرى عن وقوع اصابات او
حجم الاضرار التي خلفتها تلك الانفجارات
افادت وسائل واعلام الرسميه ايرانيه عن
طهران ارسلت وحداتنا اضافيه من القوه
الخاصه لتحسين حدودها الشماليه مع العراق
وتضييق الخناق على ما وصفته بتسلل جماعات
المعارضه الكرديه
بذريعه انعدام الامن ومنع التسلل وحدات
المدرعه ايرانيه الى المناطق الكرديه
الحارس السوري الايراني يرسل قوات خاصه
الى المحافظات الحدوديه الغربيه وشمال
غربي البلاد
الاجراء الذي تقوم به القوه البريه للحارس
الثوري يقوم على تعزيز الوحدات المتمركزه
على الحدود ومنع تسلل للجماعات الارهابيه
التابعه للجماعات الانفصاليه المتمرزه في
اقليم شمالي العراق قائد القوات البريه في
الحارس الثوري اوضح ان هذه الخطوه تهدف
الى تعزيز الوحدات المتمزه على الحدود من
خطر ما وصفها بجماعات الانفصاليه المتميزه
في شمال العراق
ودعى سكان المناطق الواقعه على مقربه من
المناطق المتخمه لقواعد المجموعات
الانفصاليه باخلائها وتاتي حركه الحرس
الثوري الايراني بعد ان اصدر العراق
توجيهات لتعزيز الامن على طول حدوده لوضع
حد للقذف الايراني وفقا لبيان صادر عن
المتحدث العسكري العراقي
وكانت القوات البريه للحرس الثوري قد شنت
هجمات جديده ضد معارضين متمركزين في اقليم
كردستان العراق
عدا عن استهداف مقر حزب ازاد كردستان
بالصواريخ والمسيرات في اطراف محافظه
كركوك
وبرر الطيران هجماتها تلك في رساله الى
مجلس الامن الدولي ان لا خيار اخر لديها
لحمايه نفسها ممن وصفاتهم بالجماعات
الارهابيه
وبينما تنفي جماعات الكرديه ما تقول طهران
وتصرفه بالادعاء لا تزال المناطق الكرديه
في ايران تشهد غليان وتظاهرات منذ اشهر
اسرى وفاه مهساه امين ملوك الشيخ العربيه
اعلنت قناه ايران انترناشونال التلفزيونيه
عن تعزيز الاجراءات الامنيه حول مكاتبها
في لندن بعد تهديدات من النظام في طهران
واقيمت امام القناه
الموجوده في محيطي مباني حكوميه الرئيسيه
ومواقع سياحيه في العاصمه البريطانيه لمنع
الهجمات بسيارات قناه ايران انترناشونال
اكدت ان تهديدات هي تصعد لسنوات من
الترهيب بسبب بثها للاحتجاجات في ايران
اخترقت مجموعه بلاك ريبورد للقرسنه
الالكترونيه موقع وكاله انباء فارس
التابعه للحرس الدوريه الايراني مجموعه
بلاك ريورد نشرت رساله على الصفحه الاولى
لموقعي وكاله فارس اكدت فيها انها حذفت ما
يقرب من 250 تيرا بايت من البيانات من
جميع الخوادم واجهزه الكمبيوتر الخاصه
بالوكاله
افاده
عشرات الاصابات في زاهدان جنوب شرق البلاد
اطلاق قوات الامن النار على المنتظاهرين
بهدف في تفريق الاحتجاجات الحاشده التي
خرجت للشوارع في تحدي للنظام
من جهتها جددت الخارجيه الفرنسيه اذا نتها
للقمع الذي يتعرض له الرجال والنساء في
ايران وقالت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الفرنسيه ان تطلعات الايرانيين الى الحريه
واحترام الحقوق تطلعاتهم مشروعه وان على
السلطات الايرانيه سماع مطالبهم واكدت
الخارجيه الفرنسيه انها ستواصل العمل
الدوليه لمكافحه افلات المسؤولين عن مقتل
امين من العقاب
حضر المستشار الالماني
سعيا ايران لتخصيب اليوراني ويؤكد اهميه
الالتزام بفعل المزيد لضمان عدم حصولها
على اسلحه النوويه موضحا ان المانيا
تتشارك مع فرنسا والحلفاء الاخرين
كبريطانيا وامريكا لتحقيق هذا الهدف
بس بقدر ما يتعلق الامر بالسياسه تحصيل
اليورانيوم في ايران فان هذا يؤكد مره
اخرى الى اي مدى من الصواب بدو كل شيء
لضمان عدم حصول ايران على قناه بلا
وصواريخ نوويه هذا هو احد اهداف السياسه
المركزيه التي اتبعتها فرنسا والمانيا
جنبا الى جنب مع الحلفاء خلال السنوات
الاخيره في المملكه المتحده والولايات
المتحده وما زلنا ملتزمين به
كما جدد المستشار الالماني تاكيده على
تعزيز التعاون الثنائي مع فرنسا بتوقيع
اتفاق التضامني في مجال الطاقه قائلا ان
برلين وباريس تجسداني معنى التضامن
الاوروبي المشترك
فرنسا
في مجال امدادات الغاز استفدنا بدورنا من
زياده التعاون مع الشركاء اوروبيين موثوق
بهم ليس من فرنسا لقد اكدنا تضامننا
باعلان المشترك الاصدقاء يقفون بجانب
بعضهم في اوقات الحاجه تجسد المانيا
وفرنسا التضامن الاوروبي
انتقد الرئيس الاوكرانيه بلادي
ميرزالانسكي ولاول مره بشكل علنيه عمده
العاصمه كيرلي سوء التنظيم الذي اصاب
مواقع عديده في المدينه كغيرها من سائر
المدن الاوكرانيه وقال زلنيسكي ان اكثر من
6 ملايين منزل في اوكرانيا تاثرت بانقطاع
التيار الكهربائي بعد يومين من الضربات
الروسيه الكثيفه
لم يتحقق توريد موارد الطاقه الا في
النقاط التي تم نشرها باستخدام خدمات
الطوارئ ومحطه السكك الحديديه الرئيسيه
بعباره اخرى هناك حاجه الى مزيد من العمل
ويحتاج سكان كاف الى مزيد من الدعم بسبب
الضربات الروسيه الكثير من سكان اكياس لا
تدون كهرباء لمده 20 او حتى 30 ساعه
ونتوقع
انا جيدا من فريق البلديه في هذا الشان
اعلنت تركيا ان السويد وفنلندا احرزتا
تقدما نحو انضمامهما الى حلف شمال الاطلسي
وفقا لبيان مشترك بعد اجتماع ان عقد في
السكر ورحبت الدول الثلاثاء بتكثيف
التعاون بالتقدم الذي احرزته في لندن
والسويد في اطار احترام المذكره الموقعه
على هامش قمه مدريد في يونيو
عدد من الدول الاعضاء بحلف شمال الاطلسيه
النيتو مناورات الميدانيه في بولندا
وشاركت فيها القوات البولنديه بالمدرعات
والجيش الامريكي بدبابات الابرامز الى
جانب قواتنا بريطانيا ساهمت بشكل الرئيس
لقد نفذنا تدريبات المرتبطه بالمهام
الحاليه لجنودنا وقد تم التخطيط لهذه
التدريبات بناء على خبرتنا من ناحيه
ومراقبه ساحه المعركه في اوكرانيا من
ناحيه اخرى نحن ندرك ما هي الاساليب التي
تستخدمها روسيا وما هي الاساليب الفعاله
التي يستخدمها جيش الدفاع الاوكراني يعد
وجود نظام باتريوت الالماني في اوكرانيا
مفيدا لسلامه الجزء الشرقي من بلدنا لان
القدرات المضاده للصواريخ في غرب اوكرانيا
تعني الامانه في بولندا ايضا
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
لهم ماسك يقول ان حضره رامب من تويتر كان
خطا فادحا ويتعهدوا بدعم حاكم فلوريدا اذا
ترشح للرئاسه
حياكم الله اعلنت لجنه اطباء السودان
المركزيه وفاه متظاهره متاثرا باصابته في
مظاهراتهم درمان الاربعاء الماضي وقالت
اللجنه ان المتظاهر قتل بسبب اصابته
بمقذوف حجر اطلقته قوات الامن
تشهد بريطانيا موجه من الاضرابات غير
المسبوقه في تحدي جديد لحكومه
هو الاكبر من نوعه اضرب اتحاد نقابه
الجامعات والكليات لثلاثه ايام بالاضافه
الى قطاع البريد والتمريض وسكك الحديد
ايضا وذلك للمطالبه برفع الاجور وتحسين
شروط العمل
في تاريخ بريطانيا
تاتي ضمن اضراب اكثر من سبعين الف موظفا
جامعي على مدى ثلاثه ايام للمطالبه بتحسين
الاجور وظروف العمل والمعاشات التقاعديه
وسط ازمه غلاء المعيشه وتضخم منذ اربعه
عقود
اضربنا يتصدر الاخبار في جميع القنوات مع
تعليق المحاضرات في 150 جامعه وطلابها
يساندوننا في هذا الاضراب الضخم على مدى
ثلاثه ايام في بلد يحاول تحويل الطلاب الى
مستهلكين المفاوضات الجاريه ونحن نعلم ان
ارباب العمل يريدون بالفعل تقديم عرض افضل
وعلينا الاستمرار في ضغطنا
اضراب 150 جامعه رفضا لانخفاض في الاجور
ومعاشات التقاعد وعقود العمل المؤقته
سيؤثر على تعليم المليونين ونصف المليون
الطالب
تقولون نقابه الاتحاد الجامعات والكليات
انها مرغمه على الاضراب لانقاذ قطاع
التعليم وكسب كرامه العمل في جامعات تجاوز
اجمالي دخلها العام الماضي واحدا واربعين
مليار جنيه والتعليم ليس القطاع الوحيد
الذي يشهدوا اضرابات
فقطع البريد الملكي هو الاخر مدد سلسله
اضرابته المستمره منذ اشهر بالرغم من عرض
رفع رواتب عماله بنسبه تسعه في المئه وهو
ما قد يؤدي الى تعطيل التسوق عبر الانترنت
وارسال هدايا عيد الميلاد
اضراب اخر ولا يقل شراسه قبيل الميلاد هو
لعمال سكك الحديد الذي يشل حركه التنقل
الناسي ويعرقل مسار حياتهم اليوم
بها فريق اضرابات في طبيعتها ليست لطيفه
جدا
اذا كان هذا ما يتطلبه الامر
فاكس بريطانيا تواجه اكبر موجه من
الاضرابات العماليه منذ عهد مرجر التتشر
ومع اعلان الممرضين ايضا اضرابا ليومين
قبيل الميلاد احتجاج على الظروف المعيشيه
القاسيه تبدو حكومه ريش سوناك في وضع لا
تحسد عليه في مواجهه قطاعات اساسيه وحيويه
في البلاد مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن
حضر خبير انه اماميه من من ازمه تواجهه
افغانستان في مجال حقوق الانسان في ظل حكم
طالبان مشيرا الى الان لان الوضع ينظر
بالتحول الى حال الاستبداد
[موسيقى]
قال الملياردير الى الماسكا ان حظر تويتر
للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب كان خطا فادحا
وهكذا ماسكان سياسه التحريض على العنف
ستظل محظوره على تويتر وان الشركه ستعيد
تفعيل عدد كبير من الحسابات المحظوره
اعتبارا من الاسبوع المقبل في اطار سياسته
الاشراف
[موسيقى]
كما اعلن ماسكه انه سيد عم حاكم فلوريدا
روندي سانتوس اذا ترشح للانتخابات
الرئاسيه الامريكيه المقرره في عام 2014
حتى الان حسب ما ذكر
[موسيقى]
اخر اخبار المونديال مع عبد الله الدرويش
حياكم الله للموجز الرياضي حصل السعوديون
على دفعه معنويه هائله بفوزهم لاول مره
على الاطلاق بمباراتهم الافتتاحيه بكاس
العالم وهو ما سيحاولون استغلاله لكتابه
صفحه جديده في تاريخ مشاركته من مونديال
وحسن التاهل الى الدور الثاني في حال
الفوز وهما يبدو ممكن في ظل تراجعي اداء
بولندا ويعور المنتخب السعودي على استمرار
تالق قائده الجديد سالم الدوسري بعد اصابه
سلمان الفرج اثناء المباراه الافتتاحيه
نحن بحاجه الى اعطاء كل المفاتيح للاعبين
انهم بحاجه الى معرفه كل شيء عن الخصم وفي
المؤتمر الصحفي الذي يسبق مباراه السعوديه
وبولندا ابدا مدرب بولندا غضبه بعدما طلب
منه صحفيون التعليق على تشكيلته الدفاعيه
في التعادل السلبي مع المكسيك في مستهلي
مشوارهم بكاس العالم وقال المدرب اذا اراد
الصحفيون الدفع بلاعب اخر امام السعوديه
فعليهم ابلاغي بالحل يعني لا استطيع اشراك
الثنيه 10 لاعبا في المباراه
بدوره يامل المنتخب التونسي في تحقيق
انتصاره الاول في كاس العالم عندما يواجه
نظيره الاسترالي لحساب الجوله الثانيه من
المجموعه الرابعه وحقق نسور قرطاج نقطه
ثمينه في الجوله الاولى امام الدينمارك في
موستراليا تلقت خساره ثقيله امام حامل
اللقب فرنسا برباعيه وتسع تونس لتجاوز دور
المجموعات للمره الاولى في العرس العالمي
فريق
اسيوي صحيح يلعب في الدوري الاسيوي لكن هو
فريق بمواصفات اوروبيه همم على المستوى
البدني فريق قادر مش يكرر ويعاود المجهود
البدني بمستوى عالي جدا على مستوى عالي
جدا هذا مهم جدا في كره القدم الحديثه
عنده بعض الخصائص الفنيه خاصه على مستوى
على مستوى السرعه فريق في الترانسيس وفي
التحولات مميز جدا يعرفوا يتعامل مع الكره
الثابته
وفي المجموعه ذاتها تسع فرنسا لحسم تاهلها
عندما تواجه الدنمارك على ملعب
وكان المنتخب الفرنسي قد حقق فوزا كبيرا
على استراليا في الجوله الاولى بينما سقطت
الدنمارك في فخذ التعادل امام تونس وعلى
بديل لها عن تحقيق نتيجه ايجابيه لتجنب
الحسابات المعقده في الجوله الاخيره
المجموعه المنتخب الدنماركي قوي ويجب ان
لا يستهان به ابدا لنلعب للثعل من
خسارتينا في كاس اوروبا بل سنلعب
بالرياحيات من اجل تسجيل اهداف المباراه
قمه منافساته المجموعه الثانيه بين
المنتخب الانجليزي ونظيره الامريكي انتهت
دون اهداف ضمن الجوله الثانيه من دوري
المجموعات وفشل المنتخبان بهز الشباك وكان
للمنتخب الامريكي فرصا خطيره من بينها
تسديده للاعب تشيلسي بوليسيتش ارتضمت في
العارضه ليرفع انجلترا او ليرفع المنتخب
الانجليزي رصيده الى اربع نقاط في مبادله
امريكا نقطتين
وابقى المنتخب الايراني على اماله ببلوغ
ثم نهائي كاس العالم للمره الاولى في سادس
مشاركه له وذلك بعد فوز القاتل على نظيره
الويلزي بهدفين دون مقابل دون مباريات
المجموعه الثالثه بدء المدرب والبرتغالي
بخساره قاسيه امام انجلترا لكن نقاط
الثلاث بهدفين في الوقت بدل الضائع عبر
روزمي ورامنج
البطاقه الحمراء الاولى في النهائيه
من جهه اخرى اقصت هولندا ولكودور البلد
المضيف قطر من الدوري الاول بعد ان تعادله
بهدف لكل منهما على استاد خليفه الدولي
كودي
جاكبوا سجل اولا لهولندا ثم عادله فالنسيا
نتيجه الاكوادور هولندا توجه قطر في
الجوله الاخيره بينما يلتقي منتخب ايكودور
مع السنجه
وكان المنتخب السنغالي حقق فوزه الاول في
نسخه الجاريه من كاس العالم بتغلبه على
منتخب قطر بثلاثه اهداف لهدف واحد اهدافه
السنغال سجلها كل من بولايه
فيما احرز محمد مونتاري الهدف الوحيد
لمنتخب قطر في هذا الفوز رفع السنه رصيده
الى 30 نقاط فيما تلقى العنابي خسارته
الثانيه في المجموعه
نهايه الموجز الرياضي شكرا لمتابعتكم
رحلت الشرطه الصربيه 600 مهاجر غير شرعي
وجاء ذلك بعد حادثه اطلاق نار بالقرب من
الحدود الهنجاريه عقب اطلاق نار في بلده
اسفر عن اصابه شخص واحد وما زال الطريق
غرب البلقان عبر تركيا وبالغاريه ومقدونيا
الشماليه وصربيا هو مسار المهاجرين الرئيس
الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
بدات تايوان التصويت اليوم في انتخابات
المحليه صورتها الرئيسه على انها تتعلق
بارسال رساله الى العالم حول تصميم
الجزيره على الدفاع عن ديمقراطياتها في
مواجهه تصاعد العداء في الصين
[موسيقى]
بعد 10 ايام على اطلاقه مهمات ارتيميس
واحد غير الماكولات تابعه لوكاله الفضاء
الامريكيه ناسا دخلت المركبه اوريون الى
مدار القمر وقالت ناس ان مراقب الطيران في
الوكاله اجر بنجاح عمليه حقا لادخال
اوريون في مدار بعيد الامر الذي يعني ان
المركبه ستحلق على بعد نحو
64,000
و400 كلم فوق القمر واوضح حتى الوكاله انه
بسبب مسافه المدار فان الكبسوله ستستغرق
نحو اسبوع للقيام بنصف لفه حول القمر
بعدها ستخرج من المدارس القمري مجددا لبدء
رحله لعودتها الى الارض
الى العناوين
صاروخيه استهدف قاعده للتحالف الدوليه في
الشدادي بالحكم بالحسكه السوريه دون
اصابات
نظام طهران يهدد محطه التلفزه الايرانيه
في لندن وقراصنه يخترقون وكاله فارس
ويحلفون معلومات من اجهزهتها
اوكرانيا من دون كهرباء يواجه انتقادات
العالميه لعمود تركيا
[موسيقى]